This is everything you need
to know about The Witcher,
Season One, in just 60 seconds.
We find Geralt in Blaviken.
He meets a lady called Renfri
and a mage called Stregobor.
They have a disagreement,
ultimately he ends up
killing Renfri.
Yennefer inadvertently
discovers she can use magic.
Ascends to become a mage.
Transforms her body to
become more beautiful,
but sacrifices her uterus in the process.
He ends up, unfortunately,
getting mixed up
with a cursed knight who
looks like a hedgehog
and picking up a Child Surprise.
Ciri is the Princess of
Cintra, a powerful kingdom,
which gets invaded by Nilfgaard.
They accidentally release a Djinn.
Jaskier gets a nasty throat...thing.
He's healed by a crazy, sexy witch.
Yennefer tries to become
the vessel for the Djinn
to cure her infertility.
But Geralt saves her with
a wish that will come back
to bite them both.
Ciri steals a
horse, kills some robbers
with her magical scream.
They go on a dragon hunt.
He helps save the Golden Dragon.
Golden Dragon then
tells a secret about him
and Yennefer gets very upset and leaves.
Jaskier gets blamed by Geralt
for all his misfortune and abandoned.
Yennefer joins mages
in the Battle of Sodden Hill.
Ciri dreams of Geralt looking
for someone called Yennefer,
wakes up, runs into the woods.
As he's walking through the woods,
he finds his Child Surprise, Cirilla.
The wait is over,
The Witcher, Season Two,
is now streaming on Netflix.
Did I win?